get started so first of all a big thanks
to all of you for being able to make it
to my talk especially during these
unfortunate times and I hope all of you
are taking care of yourselves so let me
first start off by summarizing a little
bit about Rachel's talk
so Rachel told us how you can construct
this notion of a weekly secure or a
partially secure functional encryption
and then she also told us that if you
have if you how you how you can
construct indistinguishable the
obfuscation if you have a sub
exponentially secure conceal encryption
which is a strong notion of security so
she told us about this and this mainly
follow is a beautiful line of known
results the only step that remained was
of being able to construct a sub
exponentially the sub expand she secured
functional encryption starting out from
this weekly secure function encryption
and so this is what I am going to talk
today so the agenda of my talk is to
present a security amplification theorem
for functional encryption from lwe and
this is going to be a slightly technical
talk as I will try to convey most ideas
at the same time I will try to hide some
of the technical nativities in just to
keep it light if you want to read more
about the proof you can look at our full
version which appears in P print link
2018 slash 6 1 5 which is and this is
joint work with prevention and Amit and
the preceding versions appears in crypto
19 which is a merge with the paper of
Rachel imitation map so let me start off
by kind of summarizing the goal of what
we want to do so we want to come up with
the transformation that upgrades
security of a functional encryption a in
order to construct the functional
encryption B so what we want is that we
want to start off with a functional
sense scheme which satisfies this notion
which I will denote by s epsilon
security I will just define this as
epsilon security
in just a minute but think of it as
really the weak notion of security that
Rachel was talking about and we want to
construct a function encryption from
this which satisfies standard notion of
security and in fact even
sub-exponential notion of security
assuming some parameters are set
appropriately so for s epsilon security
the first thing that I want to tell you
is like what these parameters indicate
so s will roughly stand for the size of
the adversary in the security
corresponding security game and by size
I mean the size of the adversity early
as a circuit and epsilon will is the
maximum advantage that any adversary of
size s can have in that in the security
game so that was about security however
in our transformation we also want that
whatever nice properties that functional
encryption eight had should also be
satisfied by function encryption scheme
B for example if you had public key
encryption function encryption to start
off with what you should land up should
also be a public key confident website
and then suppose the functional
encryption a had single allowed for
single function queries or queue number
of queries then function encryption B
should also support the same number of
function queries and then if functional
encryption a had some efficiency
requirement efficiency properties such
as sub linearity or compactness about
which both Rachel and Shwetha talk then
a function efficient B should also have
those nice properties about compactness
and sub linearity so at this point let
me remark something about sublinear DT
and compactness this is really an
important property and the reason for
that is that in all these
transformations which allow you to
construct io from functional encryption
under sub exponential loss in all these
transformation a key requirement is is
that of some notion of sub linearity and
compactness
like like stronger requirement and said
reality but so blend assembly narrative
for those of you who might not remember
it's just a requirement where you say
that the size of the ciphertext is
actually grows only sub linearly in the
size of the function keys for size of
the functions for which the keys are
issued so it's proportional to something
like 1 minus alpha times size of the
function to the power 1 minus alpha
where alpha is some constant so that's
what something is but it so turns out
that this allows you to basically
bootstrap any sub expression security to
I oh I won't be talking too much about
some linearity and compactness only at
certain points I will just remark how
our transformation preserves that so now
let me come to the definition that we
are considering so we because we're
calling it as epsilon security and we're
going to define it using a simulation
style definition so for those who of you
who are following the affiliate picture
there are two to two kinds of
declarations the first definition is the
indistinguishable D based definition the
second kind of definitions are
simulation based definition and
indistinguishability which notion is
kind the de facto or the standard notion
of security however we are going to use
simulation based definition and the
reason for that is there are two reasons
mainly the first reason is that it
considerably simplifies our to like once
you work with those proofs are
considerably more simpler and the second
reason is that if you could also define
this partial security notion X epsilon n
security it actually just implies
trivially + s epsilon same security
notion so basically they are roughly
equivalent in some sense so I am just
going to use the same notion so let me
now define what this notion
means so now as I was saying s is the
size of the adversity in the game so
let's say you have an adversary a which
is a two party
a one and A two and both have size
bounded by parameter s now since you are
talking about simulation based notion
there are two distributions vln I do and
the security definition is just going to
be some indistinguishability some kind
of indistinguishability between these
two distributions so so I'm going to
define this distribution table the first
step is common to both the distributions
pln idea and here the adversity a1 takes
in the security parameter and outputs a
message a circuit C and state that
adversity a my computer then in the real
distribution you have you run the setup
of Fe on asleep under a tacky pair then
using the public key we're going to
encrypt the message m honestly and
compute the ciphertext then using the
master secret key we compute the set
secret key for the function C honestly
and then you give to the adversities
tuple R which consists of the public key
the ciphertext the secret key fault for
the circuit C and the state that even
computed in the simulation 1 however we
don't do any of it we just run the
simulator algorithm of the scheme which
exists by definition you will the
similar to texas will purchase the
circuit and C of M like the function
value and it computes bunch of fake
public keys fake ciphertext and fake
secret key for circuit C and then give
gives to the adversity this tuple I
which consists of fake these fake keys
and ciphertext and the state and now
when we say that the scheme is s epsilon
indistinguishable we really mean that
the probability that the adversary a 2
takes in a tuple R which is sampled from
the real distribution and it outputs 1
minus the probability that adversary a 2
takes in the tuple I generated this way
from the idle distribution and it
outputs 1 this difference is bounded by
Epsilon
so that's really the epsilon security
notion and in other words I will just
denote for for being brief I will just
say that real ideal are s epsilon
indistinguishable so I will come back to
this notation very often bias epsilon
indistinguishability I means I mean that
the two distributions satisfy an
equation like this meaning that for all
of it adversity is a of size as these
two distributions have an advantage
bounded back sir
I use yes I have a question
ah this size of the adversity is it
going to come up later so in the final
definition that you want to achieve you
want to support any poly sized adversity
yeah so why are we why are we
parametrizing it especially in just the
next thing you start with something like
this s comma 1-1 well under security and
what we end up getting is something like
this oh I see so you change the size
yeah and remember you at the end you
need a sub exponentially security so we
start with some things of exponential so
we get some exponential a small here III
come to this they just just give me a
minute I think I will be able to answer
your question once I describe to you
Thanks okay so once we have this let me
now just jump straight to the theorem
that we proved we show that there exists
a constant C such that if you assume
that you have in every scheme which is
this secure s minus 1 minus s comma 1
minus 1 by the secure security parameter
secure and further here willing to
assume learning with error which is
secure against the circus of
sub-exponential size like 2 to the
lambda 2 DC then there exists a fee
scheme which is secure for circuits of
size s to DC and the distinguishing
advantage is 1 by s to DC plus 2 to the
minus lambda to this
now let me spend some time just just
describing the significance can I just
ask you to just so that we can absorb
these parameters so what's happening the
size if it's secured against this size s
in simulation sense then we secure
against smaller size slightly smaller
but the advantage will be lower than
before exactly so yeah so you're winning
in terms of advantage but you're losing
it slightly bit in terms of size yeah
okay yeah that's exactly what's going on
so let me enough raise it in some way so
suppose you had a Paul so by the way
first let me stress about size so
suppose you start with a scheme which is
which is secured for all polynomial size
circuits you you you get a scheme which
is secure for all polynomial size
circuit right because s NS to the C
covered all polynomials because they are
just the degree is just constant away
okay now if you started with a scheme
which was secured against some
exponential sized adversary's so if s
was some some exponential then this
scheme will also be some exponentially
secure like secure against some
expressions like circuits okay now look
at the advantage so we are starting with
basically 1 minus 1 by lambda which is
almost being close to a broken scheme
like which is 1 minus 1 by lambda is an
advantage which tends which which can be
as bad as 1 as lambda tends to infinity
and what we are able to get is something
like 1 by s to the C plus 2 to the minus
lambda T C now this part is negligible
but the other part if you started with a
sub exponent
s being sub-exponential large you get an
advantage which looks like this
where C prime is greater than 0 if you
started with security for all polynomial
size circuits you'll get standard
negligible security meaning that this
thing will be less than all polynomials
inverse polynomials that makes sense
okay so this children is useful because
now in order to construct IO all you
need to do is come up with a scheme
which satisfies an advantage which is
like not close to negligible but it
could be add with the constant at least
in the list it could be a power less
than one so and it was useful also
because in all these words that that
recently came up including the work of
Agarwal linen mat and in ours and then a
few follow-ups all of them if you are
willing to believe their assumptions
could only give you a security of less
than 1 by poly for some for some
polynomial and then our tournament can
be directly applied to give us a fully
secure
I was game ok so now let us try to build
some intuition of how partially secure
candidate can look like so let's focus
on s comma point 1 and using point 1
just because it's a nice number and I
don't want to deal with like security
functions of security parameters and so
on so forth so let's just fix point 1 is
an advantage for the next list of the
talk so here is I'm going to give you an
example how you can construct how one of
the s comma 1.1 security scheme looks
like so in order to build that giving to
use a fully security scheme okay and
then the this candidate building Fe 2
this is going to be really simple
what it does it setups a public key
smash the secret key pair from the
secure scheme and now when you are
encrypting it generates a secure cipher
text using the fe1 scheme using the
secure candidate and then it outputs the
ciphertext it well to the point 9 with
point 1 probability just outputs the
message in the peer so this is just an
example of I mean if you look at it with
probability point 1 you are reading the
message in that here and with
probability point 9 you are revealing a
secure cipher text so this candidate
not be more secure than like advantage
point one because it sneaks the message
in the clear with probability point one
so and in fact you can write down a
proof that you can show that it is in
fact s comma point is negligible secure
so why did I tell you about this
candidate the reason is that now we're
going to discuss a transformation so at
least want you to see that the
transformation makes sense for this
particular weekly secure candidate and I
should be able to see why why kind of
the security comes from that
transformation okay so so now let me
come straight to the instruction so okay
so here is the construction you have an
ingredient which is s comma point one
secure functional encryption which
gifted by God and then what we want to
do is we want to construct a fully
secure functional encryption from this
so what we are going to do is that we're
going to do some kind of parallel
repetition and for those of you who are
no pal repetition have proven useful in
various security amplifications and
there is a long long list of things that
you can well repeat and amplify and in
this particular construction let's just
say that the repetition parameter that
they're going to use is security
parameter okay so here is the here's
what you're going to do suppose you have
a message M right and you want to
encrypt this message m and construct a
secure scheme which which encrypts M
securely so what we do you're going to
secret share it using some some special
purpose of secret sharing scheme and
I'll just define this special purpose of
a secret sharing scheme in just a minute
but it is known in literature by the
name of homomorphic secret sharing so
you see that sure it share it using this
scheme and and compute T shares and then
if you want to enter this message m in
the setup you will have T in depay
gently generated monster secretly and
public a pair so this I will run using
if we set up three times three times and
then under public key PKI
you can encrypt the share SH I so this
is roughly how the cipher text looks
okay and I'm I'm going to describe this
formal detail like the scheme but
roughly this is the intuition and now
the the intuition is that since the
secret sharing scheme even if you leave
t minus one shares you have some
security hopefully some of the FE
infection should hide some of the shares
to argue that so for us to be able to
argue security so that's like just a
very very high level inclusion okay so
now let me define this notion of
homomorphic secret sharing in order to
be able to see the scheme in more detail
so what this one over fixed secret
sharing does takes in a message m and
then you can secret share it into shares
sh-sh-she as i was mentioning and then
what's so nice about this home of X
equal sharing is that you can evaluate
on these shares locally using any
circuit see using this email algorithm
that homer trick secret sharing is
equipped with okay so you generate these
evaluation shares p1 secreting and they
in order to computer share VI all you
need to do is let's locally compute in
that particular share Shi okay so and
also this algorithm is actually
deterministic deterministic and it's
polynomial time course then what you can
do is that once you have all these
evaluation shares we will do PT you can
run a decode algorithm which is also
part of HSS and it's a relatively simple
procedure and then you can recover CFM
so that's the functionality now there
are also some properties efficiency
which is only going to be used in our
scheme to I do compactness but
nevertheless let me tell you what it
does what is it about
so the size of each share that you
compute that's small that's the first
efficiency property there the size of
each share is small how small it's it's
like length of the message times some
polynomial then security parameter and
the depth of the circuit C and and then
the size of evaluation circuit that's
also small in fact it just goes linearly
in the side of the circuit times
multiplicative overhead of polynomial in
lambda and D okay so that was efficiency
now comes the main point what's the
security security says let's say you
have any adversary Aves polynomial time
force what it does it's able to cut it
corrupt some t minus 1 shares so let's
say this is some set s where the size of
a set is t minus 1 let's say it gets
access to t minus 1 shares of his choice
and then he can also ask for give Alan
Squier e on the remaining share he can
ask very like that then whatever view
that at this adversity gets which
consists of t minus 1 shares and the
remaining share that should be similar
table using the HSS simulation algorithm
so you took at you took a set s and then
he gets to run this right and this is
similar table using HSS simulation
algorithm where the simulation algorithm
it takes as input the circuit C of M and
the set of Corrections it doesn't take
the message as input at all so that's
the security notion and the good part is
that it can be built using LW in fact
you can use any of
lwe based fhe scheme of the shelf and
then use it to construct this notion so
this is known in I think quite a few
number of words so I won't be talking
about how you can turn back now yeah
question
you don't need this property that the
HSS you know output can be computed as
an XOR of the evenly no I don't need
that it all be good okay so okay so now
let me describe the scheme and clarity
once you have the notation at hand so
the setup as I was telling consists of
just the independence at instantiation
of EFI setup and the public key just
consists of concatenation of all of the
keys the key is and master secret kiss
concatenation of all the IMS key is
encryption algorithm takes in a message
m secret share is it into shares and
then does outputs this like PKI in tips
Shi using the algorithm and outputs just
these two each ciphertext key generation
is going to let you come going to
compute you run ft kitchen using the key
ms ki for this homework trick evaluation
circuit that you just saw and you're
going to publish these T keys and you
can see that once you have these keys
and these cipher text you can recover
these evaluations t1 through PT and then
the Decrypter can decode and learns CFM
so function leg functionally divides
this make sense ok so now let us do some
sanity checks on this particular
transformation let's just look at the
canonical candidate that I told you the
s comma point one secure one that was
revealing the message in the clear with
point one probability and secure cipher
text with so so there if you instantiate
that particular candidate in this
transformation and we are making T
repetitions then you will your on
leverage going to leak out about 0.1 T
times shares in expectation why is that
because that scheme leaks out the
message that you encrypt with
probability 0.1 and so therefore an
expectation event will occur those many
in fact if you look at probability that
every share is going to leak out that is
going to be bounded by this
number point 1 2 D D basically they are
all independent events so it's going to
be fine going to DT and this isn't
actually very small this is negligible
and under all other circumstances when
less than P minus y shirts are linked
out then you know that you can rely on
like under all those other circumstances
you can use h SS security to to argue
that I feel like to argue I mean with
security and in fact you can formalize
this and so but this was about like very
people that can get that idea about life
who the one which has a very light
structure how do you do security in
general and that's that's really the
question that I want to answer in the
next to me like next part of my talk so
I used one more question I mean you know
so so one way to do this sort of like
secret sharing and computation is just
sort of secret share using polynomials
like reed-solomon secret share right and
then if you compute the degree of your
computation is small enough and you
release enough shares then you can do
this company you can do this right you
can do like an emphasis like local
computation and then reconstruct the
answer yeah so emphasis like I say
you're talking about the gbbw right yeah
so so actually other it might be you
might be able to do that and I think we
also have a follow up where we do
something else like other than using
homo' fix equal sharing this just this
particular thing is just for only for
like inclusion and it's I think you know
it's similar to this packet laugh yeah
you might be able to do that ok sounds
good thanks ok so how do you prove
security yeah so ok so for some for some
time now I'm going to for a few minutes
I'm going to talk about something
abstract and vague which maybe not make
sense but I promise you that
like as soon as I'm done I'm going to
give you something formal to look at so
here's actually if you look at the
problem from like on a high level here
is the problem you have so let's say
this is a set of randomness and then
there is some procedure which where you
said you have this R which is inside the
randomness and this is a procedure that
allows you to generate some hard problem
for an adversary and you are given a
promise that probability over r ir is
hard for all foreign adversity a of size
s you're given that this is 0.9 and what
you want to do is to come up with an
analogue is setting where where this
holds that probability so now you have
all prime + r times randomness
probability over r prime i prime R prime
is hard right
see that's what your goal is but how do
you make this jump you're talking about
some advantage which is not close to 1
and you are you want to go to want to go
up close to 1 so now it turns out that
in many of these circumstance in many of
these situations for various solutions
of AI what you can do they'll did they
will often exist something called hard
core set out for set or a hard core set
theorem which which roughly means that
in many of these circumstances what
happens is that there will there will
you can show that if this promise is met
if this promise is met then there will
exist a set s such that the size of the
set is big so it's going to be 0.9 times
roughly like that but what this lets you
do is that when you sample this
randomness from this set now
then I all said only becomes hard for a
any fixed adversary of science lesson
some s double prime related to s this
becomes close to one - negligible and
this notion that lets you do this is
actually a hard core set it what it says
is that in many of these circumstances
when you have this promise you'll have a
good set of randomness where if you
sample randomness from there the problem
is actually very hard but that for any
adversary of slightly smaller size and
this in many applications lets you do
this switch so let me just now talk
straight about this hard core that
theorem that we are going to use this is
an indistinguishable te hard core set
theorem which was due to modern into our
own PCC Mountain which roughly says the
following it says that take any function
CNF our belief functions which output n
bits to n bits and if I give you a
promise that e^x when X is sampled at
random and F of Y when y sampled from
random they are s Delta
indistinguishable for some s n Delta
okay so the premises that e x and F of Y
they are indistinguishable as Delta
indistinguishable then for any desired
level of security you want any desired
level of security any desired advantage
that you want there will exist two sets
st NSF which are big enough they are how
big they are 1 minus Delta times 2 to
the N Delta was the advantage a maximum
advantage in the initial
indistinguishability so these are big
sets but now if you sample a X from this
set s V and F why will they rise sample
from SS these two becomes epsilon
indistinguishable for all adversary's of
slight of size s prime which is an S
prime is like almost as large as is only
slightly smaller and how smaller it will
be it you'll have to pay a factor of
epsilon square in multiplicative terms
if you want more security we will end up
getting security for small size circuits
if you want yeah
so that's about the theorem is the term
here or should I was I want to ask the
theorem is saying that there exists you
know this set s e and s f it doesn't
talk about finding the set right exists
exists ensure you just read it in like
some kind of probabilistic argument
later exactly exactly so I want to also
point out that Sen SF they may not be
efficient to compute and they might
actually depend on descriptions of en F
for example ok so now let's just once we
have this theorem let's just try to get
our hands dirty and write try to write
down ok so here is the first hybrid
which consists of the real world that
that were species that were CC's PK 1
through PK t the public keys that were
sampled T times and independently then
he sees t ciphertext where each
ciphertext C D I was Fei Fei encryption
of the share of the message using the
public key PK and similarly you have T
function keys which were keys for the
eval function of the morphic secret
sharing so this is what the DC sees in
the real world now we've seen this
theorem we are going to define two
functions en F in fact we haven't for
every index in T we are going to define
T functions so AI be the function which
takes X is in the input as the
randomness and then it's going to
compute the distribution for that index
so for even will produce
produce this so he I will be is going to
produce PK is K and CDI using excise
randomness and no doubt in order to do
so the shear Shi is going to be
hardwired in here so I'm just this is
like a slight video and then I'm going
to define f IX I re I can you remind us
what is X I here X is an input to this
function I'm defining a function now so
we had these functions right Ian F Smith
how does it relate to the original
construction yeah yeah yeah so ii i
takes x i's input and basically is the
randomness for generating the ciphertext
for that veto so GI takes excise input
and generate uses excise the randomness
to generate the IH or tuple like i a
triple which consists of public a secret
key on the sacraments just making sure
it has nothing to do with the message of
fe no message is always m for the talk
okay okay and and similarly fi is the
other function what it does it just for
the ayat index it's going to simulate
the public key cipher text and the
secret key using that f is ability
simulation algorithm so the simulator
takes an input the eval they and and it
takes a value which is the evaluation of
that share like applied on the circuit
see and it takes the randomness x i you
know and then once the simulation
algorithm to recover this okay that's
the effect now observe that you do Elfi
security AI and fi are actually as come
upon indistinguishable right that's the
security of fe that means there must
exist to hardcore sets SP is fi of big
enough size
satisfying the premise of the sense find
the claim of the theorem so you have
two hard cassettes which are big enough
and I also want to point out that he is
on the share fi however does not depend
on the shirai but he depend depends on
he well apply on that show
okay now let's down the hybrid in this
rotation hybrid one is just rewriting
the hybrid 0 like this so that I've got
is just e 1 x1 2 ETA X T where X 1 to X
T I chose electron so far so good now so
far we have not been able to use the
theorem because we just reiterate in the
mean hybrid so in order to move to a
setting where we can use the hard
corsets let's consider this two
distributions let's let's just say that
we are sampling x1 from uniform sampling
this is identical to doing what I will
be doing on the right with probability
0.9 sorry with probability point 9
sample x1 from the hot cassette s t1 and
with probability point 1 sample X 1 from
the complement okay now these two things
are identical
why because sampling from uniform is the
same as sampling from a fixed set with
probability the density of the set in
which case it's 0.9 in this particular
case and with remaining probability of
sample from the complement okay so these
two things are exactly identical and now
rewrite the hybrid in this form for
every index we have these hot cassettes
of density which is large enough so
here's what we were going to do we are
going to sample and alpha which is in 0
1 to the T where each alpha is 1 with
probability 0 4 9 and 0 otherwise so
this alpha is just just bear with me for
a moment it's just going to indicate
whether you are sampling from the output
side or from the compliment okay so now
suppose we have when alpha which is
sample this way for example this in the
string at least
on an average point nine of them are
going to be once so whenever we see a
one we are going to sample from the hard
cassette wherever be a ca0 we're going
to set them from the compliment and then
the hybrid is just computing even on X 1
e 2 and X 2 it here next three on
whatever units which I choose then this
[ __ ] was understand and now everyone is
identical to everything I use there is a
question here
can one a beauty sample from AC unit
cell know that you can sample
efficiently from CNM I mean it is no
guarantee in doing that does that answer
your question yeah okay so so hybrid one
is identical to happy to but but now we
have made slight bit of progress because
we have been able to manage from cell
from heart cassettes so now we can use
the dilemma in order to to make progress
so in this hybrid it's just the
intuitive step whenever we see a EI EI e
IX I and X is sample from a CI we're
going to switch it to X or X Phi of X i
where x is not chosen from the other
hardcore sir
so for example we had this in the
previous hybrid right so now we are
going to switch it to F wherever there
is a one because because of the hot
Cosette theorem but whenever we do not
have a one wherever we have a zero we
can't do anything about it because
because we are talking about sampling
here the randomness was sample from the
compliment and there's no security
guarantee associated with when the
randomness is sample from the compliment
so you can't can't switch that so we get
something like this and again in order
to argue this actually I'm hiding some
details under the rug this is just
because all these functions in the hot
process they might be inefficient to
sample with so in order to make these
reductions you have to be a little bit
careful and do some kind of non-uniform
fixing arguments and therefore I'm I'm
not going to talk about it but I can
answer it offline
and any questions about okay so the
hybrid has this structure now now the
question is are we done yet because you
remember alpha each alpha is one did
very large probably 2.9 so some of the
guys are able are now switched to f5 in
this hybrid and fi if you remember only
depends on the eval right if I actually
just depends on the evaluation of the
shares something like this so now the
question is it's no like no no longer
directly depends on the shear can be
used so my fit secret sharing property
at this point I'd argue things are like
mix security go through the answer to
that is no the reason is because we are
sampling from these crazy sets and they
are very inefficient they may in fact
they're to two problems the first
problem is that inefficient a sample
from such sets at the same time actually
both sei and SFI can depend on so you
can depend on she raised a child so
really like everything depends on
everything so how do you how do you make
security reduction go through so I will
you should know ones interrupt much but
you your two minutes of a time but you
are running all the time that yeah yeah
thanks for telling me I just a few
minutes okay so yeah so the main idea in
order to fix this is that we observe
that the density of each sets sei and
the complement is actually pretty big
their constant density then sets and so
if you look at this alpha thing that we
sample for every index it has just a
constant amount of information so
actually a random sample from these set
is not going to have too much
information about the shares and we just
need to somehow capture this and write
down the truth so the main contribution
of our work is that we build an
efficient circuit
using some techniques which takes an
instance of the form alpha are the
shares and the revaluation shares as in
the previous I'd way that I just showed
you it takes that and it somehow
outputs randomness X 1 tilde X 2 tilde
such that now this X 1 tilde X 2 tilde
down looks like the actual randomness
that you were sampling in the previous I
did I went but now this circuit age is
pretty small I mean it's not small small
but it's reasonably small so that you
can make the security so that's our main
contribution and in order to do that we
actually rely on some we actually do
some really cool techniques and
unfortunately I don't have time to go
over that but what it lets you do is
that it really can takes you to an
efficient hybrid where where you just
output something like this where these
entries are sampled from X from the from
edge and now now it's just efficient and
you can make the so this is our
simulator which is now very nice ain't
looking simulator apply some bounded
function on Omar fix the could share in
simulator so with that I would like to
conclude and I'll be very happy to take
some questions offline there are any